horizontal stretch vertical stretch we
have special names for them vertical
shift what's the next logical thing
horizontal [ __ ] well why don't we try y
equals sine X plus wait did you mean on
the outside or on the inside oh man okay
let's do it find out so can you see why
now have I trained you by the time we go
to the fourth column over here why that
has to be a horizontal shift whereas
this has to be a vertical shift you see
where the numbers are playing around and
what they're close to and therefore what
they are modifying it's that make sense
okay now look at that parabola you drew
up in the corner right when you sort of
- - you went two units you took that
problem you went two units to the right
okay so when I look at this I'm going to
take my sine curve and I'm going to
remove it 30 degrees to the left
right it's that reversed in there okay
so let's draw our normal set of axes
from naught to 360
now you can help yourself again like
it's a bit of a pedestrian way to do it
but you have this right if you are ever
uncertain use it right just like I did
over here I'm just going to play with
some values and see what happens right
if I test out X equal zero so I'm gonna
find my y-intercept right now okay and
you put them into here you're going to
be entering in sign all 0 plus 30
degrees yes but that's just sign thing
you know what side that is Tai Chi is
aha so therefore you can see my range
hasn't changed why hasn't my range
changed by the way because I'm just
moving side to side right it's not going
up and down at all so I still for a
negative 1 to 1
that makes a half right there okay so my
sine curve is gonna start over this way
that's funny okay he's a question for
you normally the sine curve takes a
hundred and eighty degrees to go from 0
up and down back to zero
normally it takes up to eighty degrees
but this guy's going to get there a bit
faster isn't he what am I gonna have to
put in here to get to sign imagine 850
right it gets maybe 30 degrees faster
right so if you've drawn
he's 360 he is 180 where my beginning
and ending is well I've gotta find where
150 is it's about there and that's going
to be my intercept 150 degrees I'll ask
another question usually the turning
point that top one it happens at 19 but
I don't have to put in x equals value to
get there what do every 60 so you can
see if that's like halfway so that's
mighty then I'm going to go a bit before
that don't know 60 degrees so something
like that is that enough for us to start
drawing I'm gonna start to put in a few
more points just so I don't get from you
myself
but this is the part of the sine graph
we're used to drawing
SEPA walked off the front do you see
that in fact the part I've knocked off
is the first 30 degrees of the ground
because I have moved everything to the
left third degrees and this bit I'll put
it back now
this kid has disappeared plus the
answers okay kilala Tristan okay so what
I've done what I've done is I've taken
the regular sine graph do you see this
like a bit missing that's been sliced
off the front I'll show it for you here
there it is okay so I normally would
have graphed that but because I moved
the whole thing to the left
it's just disappeared okay that's how
far usually draw sign but look I haven't
got to 360 yet
there's 360 on the end so now what do I
do
you remember how I lost a bit off the
front of the graph over here that bit
that I lost over here should exactly
appear over here right
just like I moved it to the left and
this part went off the view
well there was partly graph over here
which I've now moved on to you does that
make sense so the same green bit that
I'm missing over here I can put there
where's the ending point how high do I
go uh-huh
because look that's where I started does
that make sense and I have one full
period so bad should light up exactly
with mine because how do you feel about
that does that make sense yeah can you
have it got this can you draw this let's
do
[Music]
if you think you know what that last
graph looks like you got some foot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you need to watch out for where you
started see where you started it's
actually a turning point which means
that it should be nice and gentle at the
bottom as opposed to this see how this
begins sharply it's like whoops of going
up you've actually started it at one of
these kinds of spots so see how it's
gentle up there your graph is not and so
you need to change that right at the
beginning right there see that's little
bit give me your hand up if you gotta
graph hands up a lot very last one heads
up straight a few people thank you hits
up
[Music]
okay let me let me help you out because
we've been doing side side side side all
morning what I've done just to help you
is to put a little cause graph up there
because um I have that in my brain now
because I've drawn so many tens of
thousands of visible Clause X when I say
cos x I involuntarily picture this in my
mind okay but before you get there just
putting this little visual cue for
yourself is kind of helpful you're like
oh yeah now I remember what it is and I
don't have to hold it in my brain at the
same time okay now that's regular
context I'm doing the horizontal shift
about 180 degrees in which direction am
I going I'm going to the right just like
this went to the right okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm actually going to put it
up on this drawer right if you take each
of the points that's on this graph and
removing 180 degrees to the right this
spot over here which I got at zero is
going to move forward 180 degrees do you
agree you see now I'm at the midway
right I have a look at this guy see how
this used to be at 180 well I'm gonna
move him over to 360 because everything
is going to the right like that right so
what I do is I just compare these two
spots all the spots in between will also
move like this do you see that you see
what I've done is I'm just taking the
first half of cos x and moved him to the
right that looks good but then now I'm
missing the first half right because it
has disappeared off of there right so
what is it going to look like it's gonna
be this part here in fact I've drawn
this a little badly because what you
should find now and this is what I'm
going to draw is something you want to
recognize which is a bit strange